Traductor: Larisa Esteche
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Entrevistador: Ahora quiero presentarles
a nuestro siguiente invitado.
El Sr. Rodrigo, Rodrigo Bellott,
director de cine, escritor,
director de teatro.
No voy a leer.
(Risas)
Director de teatro, actor,
empresario.
¿Te presenté bien o me faltó algo?
Rodrigo Bellott: Te faltó
lo más importante.
También soy hijo, soy hermano,
soy tío, soy amigo,
y también soy gay.
(Aplausos)
E: Empezamos bien.
¿Primera vez que lo decís oficialmente?
Creo que sí, yo nunca te había
escuchado decirlo.
RB: Sí, la verdad es que nunca pensé
que fuera necesario decirlo públicamente
y bueno, hasta ahora.
E: Bueno.
(Aplausos)
Ahora sí, te saludo como la gente.
¿Cómo estás, Rodrigo?
RB: Feliz, feliz de estar aquí,
es un sueño hecho realidad
y además que me encontrás
en el mejor momento de mi vida, viejo.
E: Sé que has tenido muchísimos
buenos momentos en tu vida,
¿por qué este es el mejor
momento de tu vida?
RB: Porque estoy a punto de cumplir
40 años de transformaciones
y aprendizajes que me
han permitido, de alguna manera,
no tener que esconder nada.
no tener que temer nada
y me permiten hoy en día
estar frente a ti y a todos Uds.
sin ningún filtro.
¿Sabes? Cuando uno es niño
se empieza a afirmar y a reconocerse
a partir de lo que uno ve,
lo exterior, lo visible,
lo que uno aprende en el día a día.
Y a veces, cuando uno es algo que
es diferente a eso que es visible,
lo que no es normal,
uno empieza a negarlo
y empieza a rechazarlo y a esconderlo,
sin darnos cuenta de que a veces,
eso que escondemos
es lo más valioso que tenemos
como seres humanos.
E: Lo que escondemos,
¿vos crees que lo negamos
porque lo consideramos que no es normal?
Y en este contexto de todas las charlas
que hemos escuchado hasta ahora,
y en el tiempo que vivimos,
es una pregunta que parece obvia
pero, ¿qué es normal?
RB: Esa palabra.
Caetano Veloso dice que de cerca
nadie es normal,
y estoy plenamente de acuerdo.
La normalidad es una ficción,
una ilusión, una...
es como el sistema operativo
de tu computadora.
Todos tenemos una computadora y...
E: El escritorio.
RB: El desktop de tu computadora...
pero es una ilusión,
porque en realidad está diseñado
para controlar tus necesidades
y tus aplicaciones, pero están sujetas
a un contexto muy subjetivo
que es tu experiencia de vida
y tus necesidades.
Pero nosotros somos
seres humanos expansivos,
de cambio, nuestro cerebro se expande,
y por eso es que necesitamos hacer
actualizaciones
de nuestro sistema operativo
de cuando en cuando.
E: Muchos de los que te están
escuchando se preguntarán:
"Ya, OK. Voy a abrirmi mente,
voy a ser menos juzgador, etc.",
pero, ¿cómo podemos realmente actualizar,
evolucionar,
abrir nuestra mente de verdad?
¿Cómo actualizamos esa normalidad?
RB: A través de la conexión,
conociendo gente diferente,
viajando, leyendo,
saliendo de tu zona de confort,
pintando fuera del margen
de lo que es la normalidad.
Mirá, uno se da cuenta
de que es diferente entre los 4 y 6 años,
y no es una cuestión sexual, para nada,
es algo mucho más complejo,
es algo mucho más profundo.
Y bueno, yo miraba el mundo
de una manera muy diferente desde chico.
Mi padre decía que era
porque era fantasioso.
Y de esa manera, de alguna manera,
aproveché para negar todas las cosas
que yo intuía a través de la imaginación.
Y por eso empezó mi fascinación
con el cine, con el teatro,
con la literatura.
Y esa fascinación
se convirtió en vocación.
Pero ahí apareció justamente
el primer "no".
El "No se puede hacer cine en Bolivia",
"No hay referentes de cine boliviano",
"No existe ningún boliviano
nominado al Oscar",
"No se puede vivir del cine boliviano".
El "no" fue tan persistente,
fue tan recurrente,
que efectivamente uno
se empieza a acostumbrar
--eso es para mí--
uno se empieza a acostumbrar
y le pierde el miedo al "no".
Y así, sin planificarlo,
un día me nominan al Oscar estudiantil
cuando tengo 20 años,
y a mis 21 años empiezo a dirigir
mi primer largometraje.
Y, sin pedirlo ni quererlo,
empieza uno a salir en los periódicos
y a salir en la televisión.
Y de repente todo el mundo
siente derecho a saber más de vos,
quieren saber cada detalle,
y ahí es cuando tu secreto corre peligro.
Y ahí es cuando nosotros nos hacemos
a veces mucho más daño.
Y empieza esa negociación
entre lo público y lo privado.
E: ¿Y? ¿Qué te pasó, entonces,
después de todo eso?
RB: Cuando, creo que cuando la vida
se da cuenta de que tú te rechazas,
y de que tú te niegas, se deshace de ti.
Es como si fueras una aplicación,
un software que ya no tiene servicio,
utilidad, que ya está caducado
de alguna manera.
Y de esa manera, la vida mató al Rodrigo
del miedo, mató al Rodrigo del "no".
E: Ya, cuando decís "mató",
¿lo decís metafóricamente o literalmente?
RB: Lo digo literalmente.
Cuando yo tenía 27 años,
tuve mi primer novio aquí en Bolivia.
Y fue muy lindo, pero, a pesar de todo,
nunca podíamos ir al cine,
ir a cenar juntos, ningún espacio público,
siempre tenía que haber una amiga
que esté entre nosotros
para no despertar sospechas.
Y llegó un día en que recibí una llamada
de un periodista
de un periódico importante
diciéndome que iban a publicar
una foto de nosotros dos
que habían tomado en un cumpleaños.
Sin nuestro permiso.
Y en ese momento,
la vida de mi novio corría peligro
y mi carrera corría peligro.
Y en ese momento,
nuestras familias, que, sin conocerse,
tenían una conexión.
Ambas se iban a enfrentar
a lo que en ese momento era,
y sigue siendo, una vergüenza pública.
Yo pedí ayuda
a cuanta gente pude encontrar,
y no se logró publicar esa foto.
Pero el rumor fue tan grande
que llegó a la familia de mi novio.
Y al día siguiente lo mandaron a Europa.
Y desde entonces no ha vuelto al país.
Ni siquiera pude despedirme de él,
pero él logró enviarme su reloj,
a través de un amigo,
pidiéndome tiempo y paciencia.
E: Por eso usas dos relojes.
RB: Así es.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Casi nadie se da cuenta de que uso,
hace más de años, dos relojes.
Pero más allá de eso, de darme tiempo
y paciencia a mí mismo en mi vida,
este señor amenazó con matarme
si me encontraba en la calle.
Y uno está acostumbrado
a escuchar estas amenazas
día a día, y casi no les da importancia.
Pero este momento fue muy grave
y yo pedí ayuda a las Naciones Unidas.
Y la ONU me dijo que efectivamente
podía pedir asilo político,
pero que no me lo recomendaban
porque de esa manera no podría regresar
a Bolivia nunca más.
Y un exilio te destruye el alma.
Entonces me fui a Nueva York a sanar.
Curiosamente, ahora me doy cuenta
de que esa es una opción que yo tuve
y que muchos, la gran mayoría
de los jóvenes acá no tienen,
de salir para sanar.
Al año, año y medio,
regresé a recibir un premio
a la mejor película del año.
Y en la misma noche del premio,
con premio en mano,
me esperaban tres hombres en mi casa,
en mi departamento en La Paz,
y me atacaron, me dejaron
muerto en la calle,
con tres, cuatro fracturas de cráneo.
Y gracias a Dios, me encontró un vecino,
ensangrentado, llama a la ambulancia,
y me dice... y bueno, me revivieron
en la ambulancia y días después
de una especie de coma, desperté.
Y ese día, un 11 de septiembre de 2009,
nace el Rodrigo del "sí".
Me di cuenta de que si alguien
quiere matarte por quien eres,
tiene que haber algo maravilloso,
extraordinario, poderoso adentro tuyo.
Y fue así que se convirtió
en mi superpoder,
como le digo a mi sobrino.
Me di cuenta de que no tenía
que perder el tiempo.
Entonces, ese momento, intenté
sin siquiera salir del hospital,
dirigí un videoarte, aprendí
a caminar de nuevo,
aprendí a bañarme por mí mismo,
a cruzar la calle, cosas básicas.
Mientras tanto estaba escribiendo,
y de esa manera, al poco tiempo
me voy a vivir a Ámsterdam,
pero esta vez becado, no exiliado.
E: Es como que, todo eso que te hicieron,
cuando ya se destapó toda esa energía
que guardabas en eso que escondés,
como dice tu charla,
somos lo que escondemos,
cuando viste todo eso
es como que hayas...
hayas dejado de gastarte
todo ese presupuesto energético
en dejar de controlar, en dejar de temer,
y lo hayas usado, todo ese recurso,
para hacer cosas grandes.
Tan grandes como lo que recién 'posteaste'
y vi que varias personas lo compartieron,
que fuiste elegido por Fast Company,
de las revistas más prestigiosas
en el mundo de los negocios,
entre las 100 personas más creativas
junto a Elon Musk
y varios de ese calibre, ¿no?
(Aplausos)
Es cuando se libera esa energía.
RB: Gracias, muchas gracias.
Me encanta que hables
en términos empresariales
porque justamente me dicen,
"¿Por qué Rodrigo Bellott está en la lista
de los más creativos del 'business'?".
Y yo creo que es que,
me di cuenta, en este momento,
en esta instancia, de que los premios,
los reconocimientos,
al igual que los bienes materiales,
son pasivos y que tu mayor activo
en realidad eres tú mismo, ¿no?
El más importante activo eres tú mismo.
E: Me hace acordar a algo que
leí recién de lo que la...
la diferencia entre el aprendizaje
por capitalización, que es el más obvio,
sos bueno en algo, te gusta el golf,
no titubeas, te convertís en Tiger Woods,
pero también existe
el otro tipo de aprendizaje
que es menos obvio,
que es el aprendizaje por compensación,
a diferencia del de capitalización.
Y el por compensación
es el que tiene que ver con esto
de lo que negamos, de nuestros complejos,
de eso más íntimo surge una fuerza
desbordante que mucha gente como vos,
o que lo han etiquetado mucho,
o que lo han, en tu caso, intentado matar,
se salvan y de pronto
agarran un poder impresionante.
Ese aprendizaje por compensación
es uno de los más, más fuertes
y pocos lo usamos a nuestro favor.
¿Es eso de lo que estás hablando?
RB: De alguna manera, claro que sí.
Me encanta tu analogía.
No sé si has escuchado vos
sobre la pirámide de jerarquía
de necesidades de Abraham Maslow.
Básicamente, si no tienes resuelta
tu supervivencia física, tu autoestima,
tus relaciones con otros,
tus relaciones contigo mismo,
¿cómo te ves? ¿Cómo te perciben
tus conexiones?
Si no tienes resueltas tus partes básicas,
no puedes pasar a la próxima.
Y así, en esta escala de cosas,
si no resuelves una,
no puedes pasar a la otra,
como niveles en un videojuego.
Y ahí es donde yo hablo también
de la Ley de atracción de Maxwell,
que dice que no atraes lo que quieres,
atraes lo que eres.
Entonces si estás en una fase de miedo,
atraes exactamente eso, miedo.
E: Y para pasar de la parte
teórica del miedo
vos has sentido miedo,
¿vos ves la cara
cuando alguien tiene miedo?
Vos ves, ¿podés reconocer la cara de
cuando alguien esconde algo y tiene miedo?
Contanos un poco sobre ese tipo de miedo.
RB: No sé si puedo reconocer
en otras personas
pero te digo, el miedo es autocumplidor,
porque el miedo lo que hace,
cuando nos tenemos que enfrentar
hacia algo que nos da miedo,
el miedo a lo desconocido,
nos vemos en esa imperiosa necesidad
de ir más allá de nosotros mismos,
más allá de nuestra base de datos
que tenemos en la mente,
que aprendimos de chicos,
de expandir nuestra perspectiva,
y de alguna manera, pensar críticamente.
Pero el miedo lo que hace
es exactamente lo opuesto.
El miedo lo que hace es,
incita una retirada profunda
dentro de tu mente,
distorsiona tu vista,
distorsiona tu perspectiva,
te ahoga de alguna manera
tu pensamiento crítico
y te llena, te inunda
de emociones tóxicas, perjudiciales.
Alguien decía que el pariente
de la negación y primo hermano
del orgullo, el miedo se aferra
al statu quo.
Y por eso es que el miedo
siempre sale cuando estamos enfrentándonos
a la acción, a cambiar, a trascender,
a emprender, a ser mejores, a evolucionar.
Sin embargo, ante el miedo,
vencidos, aceptamos esa realidad
que nos ha creado el miedo,
ni la cuestionamos,
asumimos que es real.
Y ahí es donde, uno de alguna manera,
se porta bien, abdica responsabilidad,
culpa a todos y a otros y,
como siempre digo, terceriza su destino.
E: Tu me Manques.
¿Es un símbolo de cómo ese miedo
lo convertiste en algo trascendente?
Porque fue una de las obras
más taquilleras que ha habido en Bolivia,
o la más taquillera,
y el impacto que causó en mucha gente,
¿es un símbolo Tu me Manques?
RB: Mira, Tu me Manques es muy importante
porque empieza algo que ahora yo denomino
ingeniería narrativa.
En el 2014, yo pierdo,
muere mi mejor amigo,
Gandalf, un hombre extraordinario,
que además quería personalmente
enseñarle a volar a las gallinas.
Y meses después, pierdo a otro novio,
esta vez, una vez más,
por homofobia, por miedo,
por ignorancia.
Y en esta pérdida más grande de mi vida,
dos pérdidas en un año...
E: Él se suicidó.
RB: De alguna manera sí.
En este pánico que estaba teniendo
dije, "Bueno, ya tengo la solución.
Tengo que empezar a escribir".
Y dije, "No quiero ser víctima,
no quiero autocompadecerme.
Quiero convertir esta desgracia,
la peor desgracia que me había pasado
en ese momento en mi vida,
en algo positivo".
Y ahí empieza la quijotesca idea
de escribir Tu me Manques,
una obra, y me voy a Bolivia,
mi primera obra como director
y como dramaturgo,
y ahí se me cierran todas las puertas.
Y no consigo ningún auspicio
de nadie que quiera apoyar una obra gay.
Ningún fomento se anima a hacer esto.
Y es más, me dicen que no voy a ser capaz
de encontrar a 30 personas, 30 chicos
que se animen y que tengan los huevos
de hacer de gais.
Claro, el "no" a mí me empodera
y en ese momento yo digo,
"Entonces yo voy a formar
un elenco de cero".
Y encuentro 30 chicos
y los formo como actores,
físicamente, emocionalmente,
psicológicamente,
para que sean embajadores
de una manera diferente de pensar,
de pensar en el amor,
de pensar en la masculinidad.
Y ahí está mi elenco
entre los cuales estabas tú.
E: ¿Yo?
(Risas)
RB: Así fue como Tu me Manques se estrena
y... sin un peso, y además,
mucha gente nos decía
que nos iban a colgar de los huevos.
No sé si te acordás.
Y es en ese momento que,
al día siguiente...
E: Hasta sacar del país, exiliar...
RB: Otro exilio nos auguraban.
Sin embargo, al día siguiente del estreno,
pasa algo inaudito.
Recibimos decenas y decenas
de cartas en Facebook,
teníamos una página de Facebook,
de gente contando su historia, su verdad,
contándonos historias de homofobia,
de suicidio, gente saliendo del closet,
y me doy cuenta en ese momento de que
mi dolor era el dolor de mi audiencia.
Y que mi vergüenza ya no existía.
Solo había verdad.
Y la gente lloraba no por mí,
lloraban por ellos mismos.
Y la Bolivia con la que yo crecí
había cambiado para siempre.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
En abril de 2015, se estrena Tu me Manques
y apenas días después,
empiezan a salir del closet chicos
en colegios, universidades privadas,
públicas, nos empiezan a llamar
profesores, educadores,
incluso políticos, para que nos ayuden
a asesorar a estos chicos.
Y ahí vamos todos, los 30 actores,
para asesorar y para hablar
con estas personas que estaban dando
el primer paso más drástico de su vida,
que es vivir su vida en paz,
sin nada que temer, sin nada que esconder.
Y ahí es donde me doy cuenta
de lo emperador... empoderador
que es este sistema.
Y ahora, dos años después de esta locura,
nos preparamos para estrenar la película,
dentro de muy poco,
la obra de teatro en Broadway,
y muy pronto, la Fundación Tu me Manques.
(Aplausos)
(Gracias)
Este efecto, mucha gente lo llamaba
el efecto Tu me Manques,
y me hizo recordar a una frase
que escuché una vez
que la distancia más corta
entre dos personas es una historia.
Y aprendí el poder de contar una historia,
el poder transformador, humanizador,
empatizador.
Y me di cuenta de que nuestra visibilidad
es empoderadora.
Pero el empoderamiento viene con,
efectivamente, mucha responsabilidad.
E: Mucha responsabilidad.
Y hablando de empoderamiento,
la otra cara de esto, de esconder,
es que ahora ya sos una figura pública.
Bueno, hace tiempo sos una figura pública.
Y a toda figura pública,
siempre está este tema de qué es público,
qué es privado, pero en tu caso
tiene un énfasis especial.
Háblame un poco de eso.
RB: Llevo mi vida entera tratando
de analizar lo que es la privacidad.
Y la privacidad se entiende
como el derecho individual
de decidir qué, cómo, cuándo,
dónde y a quién le permito compartir
cierta información.
Y hay dos tipos
de pensamientos filosóficos
sobre la privacidad:
la privacidad como intimidad
que se refiere al espacio,
esa esfera de seguridad
donde se guarda la intimidad.
Luego está la privacidad como secreto,
que habla exclusivamente de cómo controlar
esa información, habla del qué se esconde.
Pero fíjate que ambos pensamientos
son negativos,
porque hay un estigma
de que hay algo que se esconde,
hay algo que se tiene que proteger,
hay algo malo.
Entonces, y mucho más, hoy en día
con los sesgos que hay
de las nuevas tecnologías,
de las vigilancias, el internet,
los medios sociales.
Te cuento, por ejemplo, hay un sesgo
que se llama El paradigma del secreto,
que es la tendencia que tenemos nosotros
a rechazar como privado cualquier cosa
que ya se conoce públicamente.
Es decir, si no es secreto, no es privado.
Entonces, ¿cómo proteges tú ciertas cosas
que necesitas que sean visibles?
Entonces, ahí es donde a mí me interesa
buscar otro tipo de privacidad.
Una privacidad que te proteja
de ser mal juzgado
o definido fuera de contexto
en un mundo donde la información
se confunde con conocimiento.
La privacidad debería ser la capacidad
de vernos a nosotros mismos,
de pensar antes de hablar,
de razonar ante nuestras opciones
y de trabajar nuestras ideas
de manera privada
antes del consumo público.
Solamente de esta manera,
la privacidad puede servir
la causa de la libertad y no impedirla.
Por eso es que a mí me interesa
en este mundo de post vigilancia,
post igualidad, incluso le dicen,
y post contemporaneidad.
De alguna manera, me interesa
este tipo de privacidad
que habla de la privacidad como confianza,
la privacidad como lealtad,
la privacidad como libertad,
pero no del escrutinio de la gente,
sino la privacidad como libertad
para construirnos como seres humanos.
Para realizarnos.
E: Somos lo que negamos, se llama
tu charla... el título de tu charla,
es un... parece una hipérbole,
una exageración para decir algo,
pero me gustaría saber hasta qué punto,
porque lo que decís es como que
en la oscuridad, ahí está el tesoro, ¿no?
¿Somos lo que negamos?
¿Es así literalmente o es una exageración?
RB: Yo creo que sí.
Mira, el momento en que tu vida
corre riesgo por ser quien eres,
por esconder lo que eres,
tu visibilidad, tu voz, tu presencia
es muy importante.
Hoy en día, el acto de salir a la calle
como mujer, como homosexual,
como persona trans, como indígena
o como cualquier persona
que esté privada de sus derechos
fundamentales básicos, civiles, humanos,
incluyendo su privacidad,
es un acto político.
El estar vivo y ser diferente,
hoy es un acto político.
E: ¿Por qué hoy?
Por qué después de...
bueno, has hecho un montón de cosas,
¿por qué hoy estás en este TEDx,
ante todas estas personas
hablando de lo que estás hablando?
¿Por qué hoy y no antes?
RB: Porque me tomó una vida
darme cuenta de esto.
Que el arte es la única mentira
que cuenta la verdad.
Me tomó una vida darme cuenta
de que podemos contar nuestras historias
y cambiar nuestro destino.
Y que esas palabras que nos definen
están cargadas de narrativa y de historia.
Por ejemplo, la palabra "gay"
para muchos de Uds. significa vergüenza,
débil, poco hombre.
La palabra "gay" significa rechazo,
significa muerte.
Para mí, la palabra "gay" significa hijo,
hermano, amigo, tío.
Para mí, la palabra "gay"
significa belleza, poesía,
libros, arte, flexibilidad, elasticidad,
masculino y femenino.
Para mí, la palabra "gay"
significa orgullo, confianza,
familia, comunidad.
Y me encantaría que a partir de ahora
la palabra "gay" signifique, para Bolivia,
éxito, director de cine,
director de teatro, creativo, amigo.
(Aplausos)
E: Bueno, he estado muy serio
en esta entrevista.
Disculpa que me desubique
preguntándote lo siguiente.
¿Por qué te pintas las uñas?
(Risas)
RB: Parece absurdo, pero lo vengo
escondiendo hace mucho tiempo.
Yo me pinto las uñas
desde que murió mi amigo Gandalf,
pero siempre que vengo a Bolivia
me las despinto.
Y, para mí, esto es algo que...
es un recordatorio.
Un recordatorio de cómo nos definimos,
es un reflejo de quiénes somos.
Es un recordatorio de mi capacidad
de cruzar el umbral del miedo,
de reclamar mi curiosidad,
ir más allá de todo lo que siempre temía
y siempre escondía.
Para mí es un recordatorio
de que éxito significa esa libertad
de ser uno mismo.
De que a mí no me interesa ser normal,
ni la normalidad.
Y de que en mi visibilidad
radica mi autonomía y mi libertad.
Pintarme las uñas es como un recordatorio
de que tengo una familia que me ha dado
los recursos humanos más importantes:
el amor, la fuerza y apoyo incondicional.
Y ahora escojo compartir eso con la gente
que no tiene esos recursos humanos.
Porque somos muchísimos,
y estamos luchando en todo el mundo.
Nos están encerrando...
enterrando en el mundo entero.
Nos están matando en el mundo entero.
Y estamos rezando,
en todas partes del mundo,
y estamos creando
y estamos llorando
en todas partes del mundo,
estamos amando en todas partes del mundo.
Estamos riendo en todas partes del mundo.
Estamos vivos en todas partes del mundo.
Estamos vivos, viejo.
Y eso es una cosa muy importante.
Es un recordatorio, también,
de que Gandalf tenía razón.
Y que sí se le puede enseñar a volar
a las gallinas.
Y que allá afuera hay alguien,
quién sabe dónde,
que esté dispuesto a compartir su vida
conmigo sin miedo.
Y yo podré compartir mi tiempo
y mis años y quizás,
hasta el reloj que me sobra.
(Aplausos)